et
je
bonsoir vous le savez sans doute les
télévisions canadiennes suisses belges
françaises et luxembourgeoises
monégasque vivent actuellement une
semaine francophone or ces télévisions
depuis longtemps avait décidé de
diffuser un jeu dont le thème serait la
langue française la diffusion de ce jeu
sur l'ensemble des antennes de la
communauté francophone est prévue pour
l'automne mais il a paru évident qu'il
fallait donner le coup d'envoi de la
série dans cette semaine francophone le
jeu va s'appeler le francophonissime
c'est un mot assez barbare qui doit
écorcher les oreilles mais ce mot que
vous ne trouverez pas dans le
dictionnaire bien sûr il a été inventé
pour vous faire comprendre que ce jeu
est un divertissement et qu'il faut ne
pas le prendre trop au sérieux
voici en tout cas cinq personnalités
importantes que je suis heureux de vous
présenter et tout d'abord le
représentant de télé monte-carlo
enlevez votre masque ces gens-là du
temps on se bat pierre bonsoir jean est
ce que vous étiez un bon élève en
français
3 je crois que j'ai toujours causer
excessivement en français l'office de
radiodiffusion télévision française nous
envoie ses meilleurs journalistes c'est
léon zitrone bonsoir et on vous parlait
plusieurs langues
quelle était votre langue maternelle
j'ai appris simultanément le français le
russe mais un professeur de français
venaient de lausanne continue voici un
bel hommage
mais pour l'instant avant de parler de
la suisse nous parlons de luxembourg
vite enlevé le masque que nous ayons au
plus vite
al marri carrière qui représentait le
luxembourg cherrad marie vous étiez vous
aussi une bonne élève en français
oui bien sûr mais le professeur était
toujours dans la marge un peu trop
bavard jusque là il faut l'être social à
la société suisse de radiodiffusion nous
présente michel delberghe à lille beau
soir pierre bonsoir le français est une
langue officielle tout à fait officielle
c'est l'une des trois langues
officielles que nous connaissons en
suisse il y en a 40 nationale et le
français parlé dans 50 ans sur 22 merci
de cette précision
enfin radio canada qui est représenté
par notre ami gérard dagenais bonsoir
qui dit moins cher gérard risque pour
les canadiens les français ont un axe ne
sait pas parler vous dit votre image et
je n'apprécie guère beaucoup d'excès de
les accents de tous les terroirs et bien
je suis heureux de vous présenter ces
cinq personnalités vous attend dès la
6eme qu'est ce qu'il y a six pays dans
la communauté francophone
c'est notre ami paul hermann qui
représente la radiodiffusion télévision
belge
bonsoir paul et je dois dire qu'il faut
vous expliquer qu'il faut expliquer aux
téléspectateurs pourquoi vous êtes là
eh bien il fallait que nous ayons une
personnalité que nous puissions
considérée comme étant la gagnante de
l'émission précédente comme il n'y en a
pas eu des missions précédentes nous
avons décidé de tirer au sort et c'est
pourquoi la rtb se trouve à cette table
ne vous inquiétez pas vous perdez rien
pour attendre tout à l'heure vous allez
retrouver un autre francophonissime
celui qui aura été décidé à la suite des
jeux qui vont se dérouler parmi ces cinq
personnalités l'attention doit se fier
l'ue attendait avec angoisse regardez
bien vous saurez dans quelques instants
qui va venir vous rejoindre
je voudrais enfin présenter aux
téléspectateurs monsieur capelovici qui
sera le juge unique de cette aimable
compétition et qui est l'un des membres
du conseil international de la langue
française
qu'est ce que c'est eh bien je
rappellerai ce soir qu'il ya sur terre
une trentaine de nations de langue
française
la plupart de ces nations envoyer des
délégués au conseil international en
française qui a siégé récemment à paris
et qui prend des décisions importantes
dans
grand nombre de cas et bien vous serez
le juge unique aimable mais sévère de
cette compétition chère